it's one of the world's mega cities Sao
Paulo is home to over 12 million people
it's the largest portuguese-speaking
city in the world and that includes
Portugal
it's home to great wealth and terrible
poverty
it's a deeply divided place
the perfect metaphor for the
presidential election that's tearing the
country into
their voting in the second round of this
election neither the incumbent Joe
bolsonaro or his Challenger Lula de
Silva secured the vital 50 plus one vote
needed for victory
it's knife edge stuff and neither side
is confident
many are very sophisticated but poles
have been inaccurate
perhaps the street vendors that sell the
presidential merchandise no more than
most
sallow Ariel keeps a tally of the towels
flags and badges he sells it's
unsophisticated but it's probably a good
indicator
eyes
an outright winner should be announced
on Sunday night bearing any legal
challenges what shot the Lulu camp in
the first round was how well president
bolsonaro did they really hadn't
expected that at all now Lula is ahead
in the polls still but only by about
five points in fact most political
commentators here say that it's just
simply too close to call
the two candidates have finished their
final election rallies president
bolzanaro taking to his trusty
motorcycle he likes doing this and then
the more traditional Walkabout to greet
his supporters
this is Bella Horizonte in the South a
Bellwether state that usually predicts
the eventual winner
on Sao Paulo's palesta Brazil's
equivalent of Oxford Street Lula was
greeted by huge numbers of parting
supporters as he took to a cavalcade
through the city
[Applause]
neither could win it's that close they
say the problem for Brazil is that the
divisions are so deep any reconciliation
between the two sides will prove
incredibly difficult Stuart Ramsey Sky
News Sao Paulo